[Music]
god bless
the united states
god god bless
[Music]
that
is being used by some but it's i didn't
miss it i should have mentioned it i
agree
you see obama i said obama when obama
killed osama i think you mean osama when
i smoke a blunt it's always marijuana
mother dude from tibet the dalai
[Music]
oh
mangoes my bag of mangoes up under trump
cost me eight dollars i love mangoes too
nine cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now costs 11.99
my bag of mangoes my bag
my bag of mangoes my bag
my bag of mangoes my back
my bag of mangoes bring my mangoes back
down
[Music]
that seems like a pretty good deal
aren't mangoes like three bucks each
[Music]
[Music]
raise the price of fruit don't you want
me to be healthy don't you
[Music]
the majority of the cabinet members who
basically say this is a president who's
unable to discharge his duties
civic duty and i'm proud to do it
number two now some you have to be rough
some you have to be nice you're very
long duty came in pretty big the
helicopter you gave away garage to the
kids
and it was nasty it was one of the
nastiest they say we have done an
incredible duty people came to
washington to duty help [ __ ] we have
done an incredible duty to take that
home we are
amazing welcome to to the uh fall estate
youtube live i'm jessalyn peterson
apologize for the late start but we are
black and black people are late
we start on cp time i'm glad you're here
you love me i don't really know you do
you have to know me to love me yeah well
i love you thank you are you surprised
not really were you surprised that i
threw you off the radio show
not really
mangoes my bags are mangoes
i
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures like
three by seats
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying from the
mango
mangoes
[Applause]
the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy daughter wants me to be healthy
and highway robbery is what you do
[Music]
wow what a note on which to start 2022
it is the first stream of the year
welcome everybody hope uh everybody made
it into the new year
well i guess you obviously did if you're
here and
okay anyway it doesn't really make a lot
of sense but it's great to see
everybody
you will notice that we have youtube
chat on the screen
this is a very very interim solution to
um
there's a technical error
that is affecting some channels which
prevents us from isolating the super
chats the way we've been doing for years
we're waiting on a solution from youtube
engineering so that shouldn't take more
than like a few years
uh so in any case this will allow me i
think if at some point someone sends a
super chat i should be able to kind of
scroll it and isolate the super chat
it's the best solution we have for the
time being
um
yeah we'll see
how it looks
if and when someone sends a super chat
and then we'll try it i don't know but
eventually i want to have the old the
old solution back so we're going to keep
an eye on that
extremely big news extremely big news
donald trump ivanka trump and don jr
have been subpoenaed by the new york
attorney general this is a request to
provide testimony or documents that's
what a lot of people in the chat were
saying what is a subpoena oh hold on
here we have a super chat
yeah okay i guess if there were text
associated with it i'd be able to pull
up the text as well
but um
they show up and i can kind of isolate
them in this way it's so wait hold on
here we go what if i click this
that's a test wait a second
oh there we go hold on a second this
might be the way to do it
something about this is looking a little
bit weird
right there test there we go
okay so
uh
yeah i guess i can click them like this
yeah that'll work actually guys that'll
work
let's see if another one pops up if it's
sent
uh it's such a bad solution i know but
it is what it is
i'll keep this up on screen for now
and then the chat will kind of scroll
behind it okay
trump ivanka don jr subpoenaed by
attorney general now remember
thursday
donald trump is doing a press conference
the one that'll be january 6 the one
year anniversary of the trump riots
which he incited
it's at mar-a-lago at 5 00 p.m eastern
we'll be live at 4 p.m eastern
and
it's theorized he might make some kind
of major announcement
what that announcement would be
you know
it's really anybody's guess who the hell
knows who the hell knows
but um
that's that's thursday in advance of
that the associated press reporting new
york's attorney general recently
subpoenaed former president trump and
his two eldest children ivanka who he
would date if it weren't his daughter
and donald trump jr
demanding their testimony in connection
with a civil investigation
into business practices
the subpoenas stem from attorney general
leticia james year-long investigate
years-long investigation into matters
including the evaluation of properties
owned or controlled by trump and his
company the trump organization
attorney general's contempt to get
testimony from trump was reported in
december but the court filing today was
the first public disclosure that
investigators also want to talk to
ivanka and donald trump jr
james is a democrat has spent more than
two years looking into whether the trump
org misled banks or tax officials about
the values of assets hence they did
michael cohen has spoken extensively
about this inflating them to gain
favorable loan terms or minimizing them
to reap tax savings see that's the um
that's the game
uh sir
if you want a loan we need collateral
sure well i've got this building worth
50 million oh great we'll loan you up to
80 of the 50 million great
sir you must pay
taxes on this property oh
this crappy building this thing's worth
25 million
you only tax me on 25.
but sir or ma'am didn't you tell the
bank that it's worth 50 million well
yeah but no i mean you know they'd be
stupid to fall for that
that's the that's the game okay that's
the game a super chats are pouring in
let's see if i can get them on screen
uh there's that one
can we sell tickets for their
testimonies asks teresa i don't know
that that's legal
carnage says 100
and wala is me says this is what it is
also here's one from chris
do you hold on here it is
do you feel good about bitcoin in 2022
are you buying more i am not making any
prediction about the value of bitcoin at
any point
i continue to put about five percent of
my assets into crypto
and i'm going to ride it like i'm
writing everything else
sir have you tried sartori's montamar
cheese yet i have not
i have not uh sir hello from helsinki
greetings greetings greetings super
chats giving beta energy oh my god
okay so super chats continue to come in
and i think it's uh
it's a beautiful thing maybe we'll just
oh now that we're up under a biden
regime paul mango is doing cameos for
250 bring the mango cameos back down i
agree with that
i think that that's that's an important
message
okay i do want to say thanks over on
twitch welcome to twitch the first
twitch subscribers of the year are kay
gouldi
cosmos multi-beast
slimsk
breezy
bars forever and stuck a duck putting us
at six for the day i also want to thank
the absolute first new website member of
the year it is jose pesante
who signed up with the coupon code
and is new member number seven today
just like last week guys if we get to a
hundred i will stream tomorrow and and
if we do it tomorrow i'll stream
wednesday
otherwise the next scheduled stream is
thursday
uh january 6th okay let's continue the
trumps have indicated they will fight
the subpoenas and are expected to file
court papers through their lawyers
seeking to have them thrown out a
similar legal fight played out last year
after james office subpoenaed the
testimony of another trump son eric
trump messages seeking comment were left
monday with lawyers for the trumps and
with the attorney general's office it
was reported last month that james had
requested that donald trump sit for a
deposition but monday's court filing was
the first public acknowledgement that
there has been a subpoena it is a big
deal whether anything will happen is a
different question but it is a big deal
state court judge who handled past
disputes arising from the probe agreed
today to entertain arguments over the
subpoenas which also seek documents from
the trumps in addition to testimony
as the legal fight over the subpoenas
was heating up behind the scenes
trump sued james in federal court last
month seeking to end the investigation
trump in the lawsuit claims james
violated his constitutional rights in a
thinly veiled effort to publicly malign
trump and his associates
so this is um this is a big deal you
know i'm already getting emails from
people saying does this mean trump's
going to jail is he going to prison i
still believe the answer is no
um it just doesn't seem like that's
what's going to happen
but uh this this is a major deal you
don't typically see this of any former
president or of their family so it is a
big deal this is also in advance of the
press conference happening on january 6
which of course will be covering that'll
be at 5 pm eastern time eastern time and
a major major deal
other super chats coming in
um
no i guess not
yeah no other super chats
okay we'll keep it keep it running for
the time being i do want to say thanks
over on twitch to tricia northstar jen
here
dr ubian or d rubian and kilan smalls
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 11 i do also have another
extremely special announcement there is
a new coupon code for 2022.
that coupon code is wow
22. and it you have to say it that way
you can't just say
oh the code's wow 22. no the coupon code
is
wow
22.
must it won't even work unless you say
that as you're typing it in on my
website wow
22.
um david i have a couple friends who
love obama love trump hate biden what
are your thoughts on this because i find
it strange people are generally strange
i i don't know your friends
so i it's hard for me to say much about
it
but every combination of everything
exists oh by the way the coupon code is
spelled
wow22 a bunch of people saying how is
how exactly is that spelled
um
that's the uh that's the spelling
that's the spelling
sir will the trump coup attempt to
affect the midterms
it's a f ect
okay
um
it will not
it will not that is my prediction as of
right now all right i have so much to
cover for you guys today i can't even
believe it first of all let just tell me
what you want me to talk about first
because we have a packed stream we'll
get to 2022 voicemails i have voicemails
covid is completely nuclear nuclear at
this point in time look at these numbers
look at that it's a vertical
uh coveted tests are basically missing
everywhere
at-home tests are sold out almost
anywhere they're not even very good at
detecting asymptomatic omicron
and there are a lot two three-hour
weights
at a bunch of different pcr testing
sites it's outrageous that's first and
foremost secondly
i've been
made aware
of someone named kim iverson
and i don't know much about her but i
guess some people believe that she's on
the left
my colleague john put together video of
kim iverson saying
she loves ron desantis and would vote
for desantis for president
if he ran which
desantis is trump on steroids so that
we're gonna look at that kim iverson i
don't know who listens to kim iverson
but if you did thinking she was on the
left she's big on desantis it's
cuckoo for coco puffs i also have video
of a really
weaponized arrest of a woman being
arrested for refusing to wear a mask on
a plane
i believe that this is a mental health
incident but not too many people are
saying that and it seems very obvious to
me
then i have um an ex a prototypical
example of why i think dave ramsey is
just not not the right person for any
thinking individual
to get financial advice from he's
basically just a right-wing nut who
offers financial advice and we're going
to play that
also by by very popular demand one of my
favorite ever court videos this is a
cross-examination
of an interesting witness
from a lawyer named neil rockin it's
it's a compelling video
and we're gonna look at that as well and
we might check in on what stephen
kenneth
destiny
benell ii is up to in the new year as
well
uh we might watch destiny watching ian
varsh
so we'll get to that a little bit later
there's just so much going on so where
do people want me to start today any uh
any opinions theo says via super chat
after listening for some time i feel
like supporting you financially thanks
for your nuanced and counterweight
response to u.s developments pleasure
thank you theo i really appreciate that
also thanks to dark warrior
and
kai kiljoy for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 13 and
remember that the new coupon code wow 22
is uh is up and running
um mask woman first okay let's do it
let's do mask woman first um let's just
jump right into it
there is audio eventually stand by
here it is
so the the the concept here is a woman
is refusing to wear her mask and so
police are called
what's going on
hello
how you doing
how are you good how are you
okay
[Music]
you guys
okay you're gonna just stay behind me
because i need you to ask her to get off
the plane because you're the
representative of the airline and then
when she refuses i'll take it from there
[Music]
all right so you tell me what you think
as soon as you see this get going
okay hello
we're gonna take you off the floor
you're gonna have to get off the
aircraft you're out there
and i compliment you in that way
so is it can't you tell in five seconds
that this is something this is someone
who is
seems to be on something
i mean i you know it
mental health issue and ons it just
seems like this is not ju merely someone
who is being obstinate obviously she's
got to leave the plane representing the
aircraft they don't want you flying on
their plane today okay so you're going
to have to get off they made us wait and
wait and wait yeah that's the way it is
but right now and that's fine and i will
respect that okay so i'm gonna need you
to grab your bag and just and i did not
do anything actually we'll talk about it
outside disruptive besides speak my mind
i know i live in america and that's what
[ __ ] america is about no you it
doesn't seem like alcohol to me
grab your bag you know that
you know that give me another unit on
the plane please you really if you are
ever gonna pretend grab your bag
you know what i feel my need to do as a
person just like jesus [ __ ]
christ
no i'm gonna do what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna say when i need you and if you
you're gonna do whatever you feel i
don't even think it's alcohol and xanax
i don't know i'm just not sure but it's
like this is not just someone refuse you
know
it's like there's all these things where
people are ideologically against masks
this doesn't seem to be that at all she
just seems to be totally out of it due
to me right so i'm gonna say what i have
meant to say
no to everybody stand up yeah everybody
is you're going to get arrested if you
do not stop i'm ready
you're going to get arrested if you
don't stand up and get off the air
probably already do you want to get
arrested
then stand up and get off the aircraft
that's all you have really it's not
about that man okay
i'm gonna ask you one more time and then
i'm gonna have to put my hands on you
okay for what reason
let me ask you that
you you're gonna put no no vlog
and that's fine that's fine why do you
have a right to put your hands on me
though let's go come on no why do you
have a right to put your hands on me man
what am i doing that makes you feel like
you have a right to put your hands on me
seriously though can you tell me that
can you just help me to understand as a
as a human
here's an interesting comment um
i'm a psychiatric nurse appears to be
mania so this would be a manic episode
is it live like why do you seriously
though
seriously
why can you just tell me that so it gets
to the point where they're like about to
um de-plane the entire plane but
eventually she agrees to get up
you two you me i saw you look at me in
my eyes
that's not real man
just grab her bag
yeah yeah she had a green backpack
i saw you look at me in my eyes as if
she was communicating something is an
interesting thing because we we have had
a situation on the show where there was
someone who was very very sick
and um
they would regularly send a lot of
different emails and we ended up having
to actually forward some of the stuff to
law enforcement because there seemed to
be a suicidality issue aspect to it and
we wanted everybody to be really safe
but one of the things that this viewer
believed was that
i was blinking messages in morse code to
her
with the real meaning of what i was
saying in other words what this
particular per and it was very very sad
what this particular person came to
believe
was that
with my eyes i was signaling something
different
and that's an idea that this woman also
brings up which is i saw you i saw the
look i know what you were trying to
communicate with that looked
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so anyway i don't think we
have to watch the whole thing they
eventually get her you know to a
facility
and even like a nurse comes over and
it's just like nothing doing
oh you think he's cute oh yeah i thought
he was cute too i thought he was cute
too i looked in his eyeballs and i
thought he looked into my eyeballs there
it is again abuse that
hello um yeah what's your name
all right so really really sad bottom
line i don't see that as kind of like
your typical
uh mask
refuser it seems like a very very
serious mental health incident there
um poison toad says about donald trump
via super chat i predict he'll run just
to create a situation to argue executive
privilege as an excuse not to testify
what do you think sir he's gonna have to
deal with the executive privilege stuff
and testifying
years before the actual campaign so i
think trump may run he may not we might
find out thursday at the press
conference but i don't i don't think uh
that's what it's going to hinge on i
want to say thank you to lucas wally
lucas just signed up on my website
joinpakman.com using the coupon code
there it is you can use the coupon code
obama to get a discount you can use the
coupon code wow 22 wow 22.
let's start the year off guys november
december was really rough for us from
the standpoint of memberships and we had
some time off streaming and a lot of
different things
help us kick the year off sign up at
joinpakman.com use the coupon code don't
use it it's the it's the top way to
support us and of course if you're
watching on twitch feel free to drop in
those twitch prime subs speaking of
which i want to say thanks to
buck
nast east 88
hope i'm pronouncing that correctly
that's new member number 15 today
uh
yeah
very good i i think that that's about it
okay
let's go next and look at the covid
numbers we don't even yet have the real
numbers from the hall because of the
holiday if you look really closely here
you see that on december 30th there were
572 000 official cases the real number
is probably three times that it's
probably about 1.8 million why
tons of people are using home tests and
then not reporting the results or
getting a pcr follow-up if you're just
at home you use a cvs test you go
positive and that's it
it doesn't show up here number three
a ton of people
just are it's so mild they're not even
going to get tested
they have a cold it's actually covered
omicron they don't go and get tested
so this number probably means it was
maybe 1.8 million there are places with
positivity rates in the 20 range
then there's a couple other days for
which we have data but i don't know that
it's complete december 31st came in at
503 probably 1.5 million
january 1st came in at 286
january 2nd
at 2 21
these numbers are still being filled in
the good news so far
is the death numbers are not spiking in
south africa they believe they're beyond
omicron
and they did not see a death spike so
this is the hope this is the hope
meanwhile testing is like impossible um
you go to cvs walgreens they have signs
right at the front all out of home
coveted tests don't even bother
lines are wrapping around testing sites
at all sorts of different places someone
i know over in boston posted something
uh yesterday or this morning with a
picture of a traffic light they were in
line
traffic light is like a block and a half
away
they said you have to make the line to
the traffic light just to get in the
system
to get the covet test
just
outrageous
outrageous two years in
two years in and we can barely we can
barely get testing and so many people
would love to get tested and they either
can't find a test to buy having trouble
actually get it it's completely crazy so
the hope would be
that this huge spike
uh let's see if i can get the south
africa
nope
that's not it
let's see if i go back to countries
i'll show you this south african curve
right the hope is that we see this
all the way up to 23 000 a day
and then already down to eight
which is a decline of roughly two-thirds
or more
and
not a significant death spike cases went
up about 150
and deaths only doubled so this is the
hope and we're gonna have more
information soon
okay let's do the kim iverson thing
so
a few of you
came to me over the last few weeks and
said david are you aware some of you
said david sir are you aware of what's
going on on the hill rising since
crystal and sagar left and i have no
idea what's going on but i've been told
that there's like a new cast and crew
over the new new cast anyway
and it involves ryan grimm
who i am familiar with
and then some other people i don't know
and then this woman named kim iverson
who from what i recall i used to get
messages from people saying things like
david
the true leftists are jimmy dore
and kim iverson and glenn greenwald
and i don't know who else okay
um
here's just a few seconds of her talking
about mass formation psychosis term mass
formation psychosis trended over the
weekend with so many searches it broke
the internet even her delivery i find
completely bizarre just from listening
to these 10 seconds like something is
very strange here but let's listen when
people went to search for the term on
google a couple of strange things
happened oh no oh no is this like a
google conspiracy theory some people saw
this odd disclaimer from google saying
the results were changing quickly and
that it would take time for results to
be added by reliable sources what does
this even mean i thought when you
googled something it would bring up
sites relating to the topic why would
google need time to add results by
quote-unquote reliable sources sounds
like they're censoring search results
well a few hours later when people
searched for the term a bunch of sites
began to pop up claiming it was a new
far-right buzzword well it is okay so
anyway here's the point
if anybody believes that kim iverson is
is uh on the left
just watch this clip that my colleague
john uncovered i really you know i it's
probably also controversial to say i
really like ron desantis i would totally
if he runs i'm voting for him
what
ron desantis is maybe the only person
crazier than trump in that he is even
more dangerous and slightly more
competent and could actually take
trump's ideas and make them a reality
what
so i think with rhonda sanders what i
like about for one you know i i agree
with him i would say like 75 percent of
the time maybe
what oh my god this is a leftist guys
this is the true leftist from what some
of you emailed me her and jimmy dore
these are the only people she she agrees
70 with
trump trump turbo trump 25 of stuff i
don't and it but
i like that he's uh i think he's kind of
like
i think he's a real i think he is a
fighter for the people
what are you talking about
what in a lot of ways um and i think
he's honest
no he's a complete and total liar i i
like that he calls out
the just [ __ ] you know he just like
calls it as he sees it
wow
so anyway that there's people
there's people in my audience who are
like that's the real leftist
so make of it what you will
not not someone i'm very familiar with
but from what i'm seeing
uh immediately jumps to conspiracies
that involve the left suppressing the
right
and says she would vote for desantis if
he ran who is
completely out of his mind i mean one of
the worst governors in the country one
of the most extreme governors in the
country
oh ron desantis is really a progressive
that's what it is
kim iverson is a progressive because ron
desantis is a progressive exactly
crazy
crazy crazy crazy
let me say thank you to
is it
michaela or michelle telus
who just signed up at joinedpakman.com
with the coupon code wow 22
thank you
michelle i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly
thanks to paul carl
for signing up on the website with the
coupon code obama obama you are new
member number 17 today
and i also want to say thanks to chuck
neezy
tmd lock
black white rook and nds for the twitch
prime subscriptions putting us at 21.
speaking of black white rook i do want
to announce the next david pakman show
chess tournament open to all
tuesday january 11 6 pm eastern it will
be on chess.com
anyone can play
anyone can play you will be matched with
people of your skill level i will be
playing so far
i am pleased to announce that
grand master benjamin feingold will be
playing in the tournament and streaming
it
international master eric rosen will be
playing in the tournament and i believe
streaming it
and uh hold on what is her ranking here
let me see here
uh women's fee day master anna kremling
will be playing in the tournament and
streaming it
and uh
actually i'm not sure
hold on a second here
there's one other person who i'm not
sure
if she's going to be playing or not she
expressed interest but i don't know if
she's going to be playing
so um
january 11th 6 p.m eastern the next
casual chess tournament is um
is going to be going on okay very very
exciting let's go next to the dave
ramsey thing
oh wait before we do that let me see if
we've got other super chats here
we have sort of like a intermediate
solution for super chat
david did ben shapiro commission the
miami cafe feat picks of aoc's boyfriend
just wondering given his insalubrious
predilections i have no evidence of that
chuck
but uh
let's just say it's under it's under
investigation
it's under investigation okay
also big thank you to cam saint croix
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code wow 22. okay do we want
to do dave ramsey next or do we want to
do
voicemails next
people let me know in the chat
dave ramsey or voicemails
could do either of them i mean we'll do
both we'll do both
all right let's let's do the ramsay
thing first okay so as many of you know
my background is actually not in
politics it's actually podiatry no it's
actually finance um i have an mba in
financial planning
i was at one point licensed for life
insurance
which i have a negative view about uh
now in most financial situations um
my my sort of background is in is in
financial planning and a lot of time
people call in and they say david what
do you think of dave ramsey a lot of the
stuff he says makes sense and i have to
tell you
i find dave ramsey generally speaking
entertaining but dave ramsey is
basically a right-wing ideologue who
gives financial advice some of the
financial advice that dave ramsey gives
is uncontroversially good like for
example
it's uh you know if you don't have an
emergency fund
it's an emergency and you shouldn't be
buying a new car uh you should be safe
you know there's a lot of really
uncontroversial stuff that dave ramsey
tells people
and it's absolutely fine but on the
specifics dave ramsey's views about
mortgages i don't totally agree with
dave ramsey's views about
uh some elements of the debt snowball
don't really make sense to me uh he's
got these baby steps okay whatever it's
like fine
my real problem with dave ramsey is that
he is a right-wing ideologue he is a
right-wing ideologue and there are
non-ideological places
where you can get the same and better
advice there's no reason to go to dave
ramsey here's an example of this he oh
and by the way
let me get that here's an example
someone called in
and said my husband switched to a lower
paying job
because of the vaccine mandates and just
all the entire call is crazy and you can
tell that he's acting like it's totally
sensible to take a 30 pay cut because
you don't want to get vaccinated let's
just jump right in sure
hey dave thanks so much thank you how
can we help
yeah my husband is transitioning to a
new job next month it's in a new field
and um i just would like some help
trying to figure out how to set up our
monthly budget and
some of the specifics about now from
what i understand
all the calls are pre-screened and
people are like you call in and leave a
voicemail saying what you want to talk
about and then they like schedule you to
call in so
he
he presumably he knows the reason for
the transition as the vaccine mandates
he'll get to that he elicits it but it's
like oh i'm stumbling across this no the
calls are scheduled
401k and um
yeah the just getting our we have to
start allocating our benefits pretty
soon and i
i'm not entirely sure like how to set up
our new budget because i don't know
exactly what the take-home pay is going
to be
the catch is that he's going to he's
making a little bit less money with this
new job
why um well he wanted to
i mean in the simplest of terms he
didn't really have a feature at his
current company due to the mandate so
he kind of saw the writing on the wall
and so he decided to get out while the
kid was good
he didn't have a future at his company
because of the mandates and he decided
to get out while the getting's good and
dave goes okay okay yeah as if that's
logical let's continue okay so he had to
kind of switch fields
um the good news is his new you know the
real financial advice is hey maybe a 30
pay cut because you don't want to get a
vaccine that a billion people have
gotten and helps protect you from
serious illness and death that's a
stupid financial decision dave ramsey's
known for tough love he'll go don't buy
the car sell the car stupid this is
stupid that's stupid
the the good financial advice is
you're taking a 30 grand pay cut
because you refuse to get vaccinated and
now you've got to re-budget your whole
life
and and delay the savings that's the
advice that you should be giving as a
financial advisor
don't take a 30 paca go get vaccinated
okay let's continue new job is 100
remote
and it's based out of texas so we feel
like we have a little bit of security
there
the job is based out of texas so we're
going to get a little bit of security
there what does that even mean what does
that mean we're gonna it's we're gonna
have security because of the job
if it's remote anyway what what what is
he talking about
and and the reaction here is like this
is all normal
the reaction should be
you gave up 30 grand
because you had to get vaccinated
do you have kids do they go to school
did they get their vaccines you know i
mean it's like you
what
has upside
the yeah the upside is that it's it's
remote so right so she's saying the
upside in terms of not having to get
vaccinated he's saying is there room for
growth and the upside is he's not going
to get fired for vaccines but but but i
mean is there a career ladder upside
yeah so i mean definitely very he's kind
of start at the bottom again um but the
trajectory it looks really good and you
know the current job i mean he wasn't
allowed to go into the corporate office
so you know it's like you could take a
step back and go
i am i am not going to comment on the
vaccine part but as a financial advisor
choosing to take a 30 000 pay cut and go
back to the bottom of the ladder
is something i would try to avoid it's
not great for your savings plan to lose
30 grand a year like that's that's the
financial advice
there was i mean his future there was
kind of over yeah i understand okay i
understand
i understand um the uh
we're getting a lot of people joining
ramsey some really high quality people
joining ramsey
high quality people are joining ramsey
for the same reason they you know they
reach the end of their
um time with their other company based
on their
uh policies and so forth so yeah it's
it's a lot of people looking for another
place to work and so he's saying he's
actually saying this is logical he's
like yeah we're hiring a lot of those
anti-vaxxers ourselves really high
quality people now dave ramsey's company
um
just so you know who we're getting
advice from here
uh right take a look here
check this out this is this is who's
giving you the financial advice okay
uh oh man this is this half the page is
half the page is an advertisement here
we go dave ramsey fired staffer for
taking covet precautions lawsuit says
brad amos says when he requested to work
from home to protect his high-risk
family members from kobed he was told
pray
and keep moving forward
the lawsuit stated
okay this is the guy who's going yeah
we're getting some qua high quality
people
at ramji
um there's another one here
uh
oh wait a second hold on
it's like
a lawsuit okay i'm not even able to find
it right now
former taking cove at 19.
yeah pray away okay there's other ones
there's other ones so
you have to understand like it is
extraordinarily cult-like and this is
not the guy
you want to get financial advice from
the uncontroversial stuff
there's so many simple personal finance
books don't read rich dad poor dad
that's a whole other scam okay don't
don't don't do that
um
you can get the simplest this the simple
stuff you could write on one page and in
fact a blogger like mr money mustache
can give that stuff to you
um
he'll end up recommending now now watch
let's just continue okay here we go um
all right now the uh
you're you're out of debt except and you
have your emergency fund
yeah we actually we moved earlier this
year and we um we bought a new home and
so we have we have a pretty sizable nest
bag now but we're completely out of debt
except that's our mortgage okay all
right very good
all right so you'll be putting 15 of
your income into 401k right
so his company will match 36 of 6
of the 401k so
the problem is it means less money and
so when we bought our home
the mortgage was very very very
comfortable um with his old job and well
so it sounds like you're choosing to
create a whole bunch of problems for
yourself by just not getting vaccinated
taking a little bit of a step back what
did he used to make um
about 130 what does he make now
he's going to make a hundred
and
so you're thinking of backing off the
401k at least for a little bit until you
get settled in
yeah okay okay i wouldn't do it
permanently but i might do it for six
months or even a year while you get
settled into the new numbers okay the
old 401k i would get with a investor pro
just click smart fester at ramsey yep
hire them to help you with that
solutions.com find someone in your area
that you like and that we endorse that
does someone endorsed by them sorry
stuff the way we teach and you know
they're ramsey trusted people right and
so um
sit down with them and do a rollover on
the old 401k roll it to an ira uh do not
put it don't if it wasn't in a roth
don't move it to a roth don't make it
taxable but a direct transfer rollover
has no taxes coming out at all so you
want to go ahead and get that set up you
can do that after the first the year
that's fine but i wouldn't leave it over
at the old company
then the second thing is you can start
your 401k you're definitely going to get
that six percent going in you may want
to go ahead and go on up to 10 and then
let's see how we're doing from there as
far as your budget goes
i mean
you're guessing and after one month
you'll adjust it and you'll know so just
give yourself plenty of wiggle room but
you've got a big nest you got some money
laying around from the sale of that
house right
so if you miss it a thousand dollars you
just pull some money yeah anyway so you
know the thing about with dave ramsey is
you you don't need to it's it's kind of
like a jordan peterson thing as i've
said before
jordan's peterson says some insane
things and he's generally speaking you
know a right-wing uh a
christian guy right i mean at the end of
the day he he doesn't always wear his
religion honestly but he's a right-wing
christian and a lot of the stuff he says
is just pretty basic on controversial
stuff about getting your life in order
and whatnot you can get that same stuff
without the ideology and the wackiness
in many many other places but it might
take a little bit of work the stuff the
reason this and jordan peterson and all
that stuff is so popular is it's just
spoon fed to people
and it's signal boosted etc okay so
anyway that's the dave ramsey thing um
don't get financial advice from dave
ramsey you know just just there's it's
not it's not necessary
um
and uh he he is a right-wing nut at the
end of the day he's a right-wing nut
look at the lawsuits look at the covet
stuff it's really really crazy i want to
say thanks to twitching
nicholasdb and mr vister
for the twitch prime subscriptions i
really appreciate that we are at 25 it's
the first stream of the year i will
stream tomorrow if we get ourselves up
to a hundred two ways to do it one is
sign up at jointpakman.com
two is make a twitch uh subscription
and three
we will count patreon pledges double if
you go to
patreon.com david pakman show and make
the smallest pledge you can even two
bucks
it'll count as two
why not we really want to get going you
know with a lot of momentum uh this year
all right let's get to some of these
other messages that have been coming in
we've got kind of like our interim
super chat solution there are no super
chats okay all right it's working okay
not great
but i'm going to continue
keeping an eye on that all right let's
now do voicemails because i have i have
been delaying voicemails for some time
uh let's see what we got it's here's the
first voicemail of the year from whitney
welcoming us to 2022.
so i was looking at the enneagram test
and thinking about it in relation to
like genders
and then um
also
how people feel like you know maybe
slavery wouldn't be such a bad idea and
it's obviously like
in pertains to like women and
um
you know uh
basically okay and a second message of
peace and love from whitney
so getting more into the enneagram test
something
um correlates to gender and you know how
um
exactly
okay so that's that next is the first
call of the year from troy york these
may be the only calls from these people
this year by the way hi yeah dave i'm
watching your video
on new denver schumer
i believe his name is mccloud
and uh yeah in the video you said that
this is only one shooter
then you're focusing on it yeah
uh i'm guessing that you're only
focusing on this one shooter instead of
110
because it's a rare case
[Music]
uh then you continue on white
nationalism and white people in general
as somehow this man's all indicative of
the extremism and i know how you threw
trump's name too
okay
uh i don't know what the guy's talking
about but it's all of course very very
interesting
this might be the same guy let's see
and so the overarching colonial ruling
powers
actually overthrew
that indentured
servitude newly freed and ventured
servant government
they overthrew that elect that elected
official
and they executed it executed
some of the perpetrators of the native
american
genocide wow that's uh that's pretty
serious
first day of 2022
pacific coast time nine thirty
two
so i just had an epiphany
because i'm watching the young turks
and
often
so they're broadcast i don't i don't
have
i don't know the terminology blogs blogs
whatever i watch you guys on youtube
and including yourself and dolmore and
several others that i've just chosen
that are
intelligent people
but i just realized today
when when you're repeating statements in
mockery
the idiots
actually think when they're watching
this they don't have
the minds okay and
to all right all right let's try let's
try one more okay
hi david my name is dan fultzer from
albany new york and a frequent westerner
of yours and i wanted to wish you a
happy new year
and thank you
share two thoughts first thought is
could 22 be the year we finally see
justice against trump here's the whole
thing
the other side of the coin is fear about
the fall
uh 22 midterms
and whether
uh the
gop threat to democracy will further
materialize
so keep up the good work enjoy listening
to you and
again have a happy new year all right
well very important questions we just
don't have answers to them yet
jody asks via super chat one more time
do you think
guillen maxwell will throw trump under
the bus i actually don't think she will
i hope she will but i don't think she
will
curious to hear what others think about
that i also want to say thanks to tim
poole's girlfriend for signing up via
twitch prime twin twin pool's girlfriend
is new member number 26 today which i
very much appreciate all right let's get
to this video this has nothing to do
with anything on the show but a bunch of
different people over time have told me
this video is fascinating and we should
look at it here oh we did get a 10
british pound super chat from andy keep
up the good work good sir please
remember us poor flippers over here in
the uk with brexit it's flipped up to be
honest happy new year man uh of course
andy we we remember all of you guys
thank you all right this is just an
interesting cross-examination there's a
lot of different interesting aspects to
this let's just jump right into it see
what you guys think it is one of the
most entertaining videos i've ever seen
and just so you guys know
uh we're gonna hear from the defense
attorney neil rockin who is defending a
guy
who
allegedly gave drugs i think to this guy
so this is a prosecution witness being
cross-examined it's very interesting
let's
just enjoy it just sit back okay
really prepare yourselves for this
this is this is something
mr spencer i'm going to ask you some
questions okay
okay
questions i ask you should generally
call for yes or no answers if you can't
answer it that way you let me know all
right
yes
um
mr spencer you have been around people
who have
used narcotics haven't you yes
um and you've seen people who in your
experience appear to be high haven't you
yes who appear to be under the influence
of some kind of a drug or affected by
some kind of a narcotic haven't you
yes can you look the jury in the eye and
tell me whether or not you've taken any
narcotics today
prescription pills anything of that sort
xanax opiates
yes i have taken prescription pills
today i've taken when did you last take
a prescription pill today uh this
morning what time
um i'd say around nine o'clock and what
what medication did you take this
morning around nine o'clock before you
came to court i took five minutes
vivants five answers and amphetamine yes
i'm personally advances for adhd yes
the behavior that the way that you're
communicating and i'm gonna speak to you
try to speak softly and have a dialogue
with you okay
okay
the entire speak softly thing is is a
clever tactic because it's like
does he need to be speaking softly but
he's already kind of creating this
environment where he's like this guy
could flip out at any second the way
that you're communicating now
um isn't this the way that you've seen
people communicate in your own personal
life who appear to be high or under the
influence
judge i'm not objective
so he can ask him if he's higher under
the influence but happened
to evaluate his
i don't understand the question okay
i don't understand how i could look at
myself from a third person view so you
well first of all so the the prosecutor
objected your honor send your question
again
yeah sure
the way that you're communicating now i
mean can you hear i withdraw and i'll
ask it differently can you
no i'm not okay this is the way that you
normally communicate
i don't normally communicate from us
from a stand in circuit court
in a case involving an older man that
through parties with underage people
providing drugs i'm nervous if you're
accusing me of being drugs then you're
doing a very bad job being drugs you
should be asking no he's not actually
gonna help your client okay next
question
i appreciate that now i'm angry and i'm
gonna tremble my voice even more not
because i'm on drugs but because i'm
nervous
and you're intimidating that's what you
do okay it's not gonna work judge losing
control of it quickly
that's my answer okay well we'll um
we'll just answer his questions and
we'll get you out of here okay
all right thank you
today you um you testified a few moments
ago to the jury
in response to ms hans questions that
joe has
provided you with ketamine on prior
occasions at his house correct
and you said it was almost i think i
wrote down
i said almost every time you were there
you remember yes
and
at the
preliminary examination that was when
you testified before in district court
you remember that
yes and you took an oath at that time is
that right
yes and at the time you were
um
that was closer in time to the
the events of february 15. true okay
and you told the
that time you
were asked this question and this was
your answer on page 62.
this gets wild how many times had you
ingested ketamine that the defendant
gave you at his house
your answer
it was one time it was that night
wasn't that your answer under oath at
the preliminary examination
yes it was today you've told the jury
something different haven't you
yes i have
so
two times under oath you've given two
different answers
true
true
both of those pieces of testimony can't
be true right
if
i know you said to only keep this yes
and no but i'd like to explain that
this isn't about the amount of times
that i did ketamine at joe's house
this is about
it
it goes beyond that
i
like i've stated multiple times
i was very inebriated every time that i
was at his house i may have even been
given ketamine without knowing it
you've never told the police before in
response to i have a question let me
finish my question look you'll get every
opportunity mr spencer i'm keeping my
voice very calm everybody's relaxed
every opportunity to talk as much as
you'd like everybody's calm never before
today in front of this jury made an
allegation that somebody gave you
ketamine without your knowledge isn't
that true
can you please rephrase the question yes
until just now
you've never
told the police or accused in a formal
setting in this case
joe of having given you ketamine without
your knowledge
right correct that's something new that
you just told the jury now
well maybe it was something that i
didn't consider when i
first stated that i only did it one time
i'm sorry
i'm asking you i'm moving on to another
subject
you're here testifying in court you
understand that correct
yes yes
you've just made another allegation
against
mr shield
that he drugged you with ketamine
without your knowledge
isn't that true that's what you just
told the jury
yes it is
never told that to any police officer
formally nor did you testify to that
previously in this case i may have
mentioned it before
i'm not sure there were so many times
that i talked to
detectives you just told the jury a
second ago that it didn't dawn on you to
think about that now you're saying that
you actually may have said something
about that those are two different
things aren't they
uh oh
do you want me to go back and explain
myself no i'm asking you a specific
question mr spencer
yes
okay
so
your testimony today includes a new
allegation against mr shiel that you
were
somehow drugged plenty of adrenaline
i'm not i'm not saying that i'm saying
that it's a possibility i'm not saying
that that's that that specifically
happened i'm saying it's a possibility
as in
the guy currently being charged might
have secretly given me ketamine well
that's a big allegation there's no way
anybody's ever gonna be able to know
that i don't even know that myself i'm
just saying possibly and maybe i
considered that when i just said that i
took ketamine multiple times at his
house maybe i considered that it's a
possibility but there's no way i'm ever
going to know if it actually happened
that's what i'm implying
i'm not implying i'm not alleging him of
anything
under oath prosecutor asked you on
direct examination
whether mr sheel whether had provided
you with ketamine
prior to
um
at the time she went to his house she
asked you that why is this so compelling
i can't even really put my finger on it
very simple question do you remember
do you remember the question and answer
a few moments ago
yes
and you said yes
she's and you said almost every time i
was there
yes and you're saying that when you told
the jury that underwrote that you were
thinking to yourself that maybe it was
given to me without my knowledge is that
your explanation for that testimony
under all
yes it is
that make any sense to you
that you would answer a question
directly that he gave you drugs in the
past gave you ketamine in the past but
now when i'm questioning you it's well
maybe it was
maybe i was thinking of maybe i was
drunk and didn't know it that's why i
answered it that way
is that really the explanation you want
the jury to accept
i don't know how else you would want me
to explain this
i i
i would appreciate if you can move on to
the next question
i'm sorry
let me move on to the next question yes
the questions i'm asking are
mr spencer
pointing out we're done with this topic
contradictions in your testimony do you
understand that
so i appreciate you would like me to
move on but i'm sure you can appreciate
that
the judge will ultimately tell me when i
have to move on you understand that too
right correct okay
you want me to move on because it makes
you uncomfortable to have to
getting caught in
what is
untruthful testimony well there's a lot
of these really small discrepancies like
how many times did you do this how many
times blah blah blah blah that like i
didn't just like
this isn't
like a test that i studied for this
isn't college this isn't something that
i think is like a huge deal so when you
guys throw all these questions at me and
then throw it on the record it's not
something that's like constantly running
through my mind every day and i'm
remembering all these little tiny
little details and splitting hairs about
it that's what i'm doing you think i'm
splitting hairs
i'm questioning you about the
truthfulness of your testimony and
contradictions and you're telling the
jury that that's splitting hairs
is that what you say you're
characterizing my time i don't even
totally understand how this is all being
allowed to be completely honest to
answer all these questions to the best
of my ability we'll get to the reasons
why you're here later okay
do you understand but i'm still going to
put these questions to you is that okay
with you mr spencer yes another question
thank you
you said today that um
you
told the prosecutor today in response to
her questions that every time you went
to joe's you got drugs
is that what you to that is what you
testify to today right
yes okay
isn't your story evolving from what it
was when you testified at the
preliminary examination isn't it growing
evolving
aren't you exaggerating
i think you may be
um
i think you
maybe
you're
you're mistaking exaggeration for
lack of memory
and um
quite frankly like my
i don't want
to remember the things that happened at
joe's house i've been trying to forget
them for a year
you're mistaking his exaggeration from
my lack of knowledge and care about that
entire situation
it's been a very long time since the
last
testimony and i thought that i put all
of that behind me
you didn't think you'd be coming back
here again
i was really not expected
i was not expecting to come back here at
all so i'm putting to you the
questions and i'm trying to do it as
calmly as i can let me ask it again okay
um isn't it true um i don't really like
the way that the beginning of question
let me withdraw that
your story your claims about joe and
what took place at his house
are evolving they are growing isn't that
true
i would not say that that's true okay
let me just briefly pause and thank
chief boris as well as the freak and j.p
de beast already exists
and twisted hawk for the twitch prime
subscriptions i really appreciate that
also want to say uh thank you and a
welcome to eric picula who just signed
up on my website joinedpakman.com using
the coupon code obama
and his new member number 31. okay let's
continue
you um
testified today that on the
on february 15th
that you drank alcohol that's what your
testimony was under oath just a few
moments ago to the jury
right
correct
you were asked this question at the
preliminary examination page 62 lines
18-19
did you drink alcohol that night
your answer was no i did not
correct
correct
again your
testimony today is different than it was
at the preliminary examination when you
testified on the road there
right
correct
again
different in the way that it's evolving
worse for joe
making joe look worse and worse and
worse
isn't that what you're doing here
i don't think that's my intent
i think my intent is to just tell the
truth
you told the jury a few moments ago in
response to ms han's questions
that
she asked you about nitrous oxide
remember those
yes she asked you about whether or not
you would you asked you about cocaine
being provided to you at joe's house do
you remember that yes you said that joe
had provided you with cocaine again you
said that that was your testimony on
direct examination do you remember that
yes that's not true
is it
pardon me joe never gave you cocaine and
you didn't do cocaine at joe's house
that's a lie
right
please
can you please
rephrase the question the question was
confusing to you
no can you just
yes you testified
today that joe gave you cocaine and you
used cocaine at joe's house
previously that's what you testify to
today
we've acknowledged that
i'm putting to you that that is not true
that is a lie
correct
that is not why
i did use cocaine at joe's house
okay on page 61 lines 15 17. at the
preliminary examination where you
testified closer in time the question
was what do you did you partake of the
nitrous oxide or the cocaine
your answer was no
but i've heard and seen it at his house
on occasions wasn't that your answer
underwrote then
oh boy
that may have been i don't know i
haven't
both of those can't be true mr spencer
okay so that was your answer at the
public exam correct yes okay that's the
next question both of those can't be
true what you testify to today to the
jury and what you testify to under oath
at the preliminary examination right
yes
so one of them is a lie
i was lying about not using them
you were lying at the preliminary
examination i felt guilty because my dad
was in the room okay
at the preliminary examination you were
under that's just so the jury
understands that you took a note before
you testified
in the preliminary examination is that
correct
i didn't want my dad to hear that i was
using cocaine
you took an oath to testify to the truth
at the preliminary examination in
district court right
correct you raised your right hand just
as you did today
correct you looked there was a judge
there named judge nancy carniak right
correct you looked her right in the eye
and answered the question no isn't that
true
and your testifying now is that was a
deliberate intentional lie
he said yes
isn't that perjury
yes it is okay i'll rephrase it you you
recognize the that when you're under
oath i like how he's asked is that
perjury there's an objection like you
know he you can't ask him about the law
it's just a witness and he goes yes it
was
he goes right through the objection it's
the penalty of perjury don't you
yes
you understand deliberately and
intentionally lying under oath for any
reason is perjury do you understand that
yes i do
so you concede that you committed
perjury from your own perspective by
your own words you committed perjury at
the preliminary examination
yes
when the police entered the house that
night you were in possession of
drugs right
yes i was
and tell us again what drugs you were in
possession of
xanax xanax how many xanax pills were
you in possession two
and you did not have a prescription for
those pills isn't that true
that's true
you understood at the time you were
possessing that it was a crime to
possess them isn't that right yes i did
understand that you understood that it
was a serious crime
yes and you understood that it was a
felony
yes i did understand that so you knew
that when the police entered into the
house that night that you were
committing a felony
yes you knew that you were committing
multiple felonies if you count the
number of pills you possessed isn't that
true objection
i would try true i would trot it's fine
i would draw it
i'm asking questions very politely about
it
do you know that's not true
well i don't know i don't i i i resent
that because
because i'm not i'm not suggesting that
that i know that that's not true and i
don't like to suggest you know me i'm
not suggesting
if you have anything i'm not i'm asking
a question
you know what then
i'm asking a question if i'm wrong about
that then then i'm wrong about that i
certainly will withdraw that all right
so
so i i will withdraw that
and when the police entered the house um
you you actually as they answered you
what did you do with the the bag of
pills that you are the couple of pills
you had were they in a bag
they were in a piece of uh
like plastic wrap from cigarettes you
remember that
you remember the yes it was in my pocket
the plastic wrap thing is interesting
you know when i was in lisbon portugal
um
there was a guy who came up to me
when i was sitting at a cafe offering
drugs and when he pulled it out of his
pocket to show it to me
it was something wrapped in like a piece
of plastic wrap cellophane it was the
same thing but
i thought it was like hash related in
some way i don't remember exactly what
it was that's that's interesting the use
of cellophane for transportation
you have a good memory of that
yeah because there were cops and i had
drugs on me i threw them okay it was
like an instinct
your goal you told the jury today that
your goal was to
to be deceptive with the police when you
threw the
the drugs away from you right yes i
wanted to make it look like they were
not mine
now at the preliminary examination i
asked you questions about that when you
were underrolled previously and what was
your
goal
in discarding the drugs do you remember
that
yes i did
and originally you lied
under oath at the end i didn't
understand the question correctly
can i let me just finish the question
you can answer it any way you want if
you want to argue with me that's up to
you i'm just going to ask the question
okay
isn't it true that at the preliminary
examination when i first asked you
wasn't it your goal to deceive the
police
and through the drugs that you lied you
denied people asking the point of this
witness
this is one of the main witnesses that
the prosecution used to
[Music]
confirm
that joe the defendant did bad things
and what the lawyer is doing here is
pointing out or trying to point out that
this witness
can't be trusted because he's giving
conflicting testimony under oath now
versus under oath during the preliminary
hearing your intention
i don't remember maybe i did deny it but
i i don't really see any other reason
why i would throw them
obviously i was trying to deceive the
police i think it was foolish of me to
say no and if i did i may have not even
realized that i was saying no
well the question i asked you wasn't
this your question and the answer at the
preliminary examination line 7 8 79 line
7 through 11 was
your goal in dropping them to the floor
was to attempt to see the police right
and your answer was i don't know if it
was to deceive the police it was mostly
just so that i wouldn't get in trouble
because i wouldn't want to get in
trouble so yeah
i was trying to deceive the police
that's what happened and then i
questioned you further
and ultimately after you originally
denied that it was your goal to deceive
the police ultimately i originally
i was not denying i
originally
said
i was trying to not get in trouble as in
i was trying to deceive the police into
not thinking that they were mine the
whole time i was agreeing that yes i was
trying to deceive the police by throwing
them
that's what you ultimately arrived at
after you and i had a long exchange
under oath isn't that true i i
i stated that
initially you just tried to twist it
around to make it look like i was saying
something else and it took forever
your goal in dropping them to the floor
was to attempt to deceive the police
right today you answered that question
very promptly to miss hand you said yes
at the preliminary examination you said
i don't know if it was to deceive the
police that's how you began the answer
those
and then i further i went on to say i
was doing it so that i wouldn't get in
trouble that is deception
that's the definition of deception i i
can i concur
so so what are you what are you getting
at
your initial reaction when you you first
thought
when the police came into the house and
you were in possession of drugs your
first thought to yourself was
i should be deceptive
[Applause]
is that right
answered i think he's admitted
okay uh it's yeah yesterday
you tried to um deceive the police at
that time because you believed at that
moment that was in your best interest
isn't that right correct all right
so at the time did you think that that
was okay
acceptable appropriate
yes
so
deception is is a tool that you
personally use when you're
confronted with a problem or with
trouble
i don't like to ever have to deceive
anybody but in that situation
yes that's a like you said a potential
felony and
in my mind quite a bit of trouble would
come out of that
for having
two little prescription pills in my
pocket that someone gave to me
yes i yeah i
that is
a tool that i use deception it's not
something that i like to use and i hate
to admit that it's not like i do it all
the time it was a survival tactic that i
that i chose to do that's so deception
is something you use yeah i think it's
something that everybody uses at least
once in their life whether they have to
or want to
it's
yes
wow
wow wow wow so that's about half of it
we're not going to watch the entire
thing but you can you can find it um
cooperating witness cross-examination by
attorney neil rockin it's it's quite a
scene it really is i want to say thanks
to the hobo as well as cortina and
sparky
and nikki
all for signing up via twitch prime
today i very very much appreciate that
okay everybody that's going to be
everything i had for today we are going
to be streaming the trump press
conference live on thursday that's at 5
p.m eastern i will start at 4 p.m
eastern
4 p.m eastern so i hope you'll join me
then on thursday and then you may see me
you may see me between now and then all
right everybody hope everybody had a
happy new year welcome to 2022 the new
podcast is out clips are out it's all
out it is all out and we'll see
everybody very very soon